Developer is not only to code.
It's about inventing and creating new things.
You need to put something
of you,
make it personal and I think that this is a form of art.
I am Vincento Colucci, I am
twenty-five years old.
and I'm a developer here in Manfredonia, Italy.
Being a developer gives you the same
power
of an inventor, and my dad always taught me that
if you need something, you can build it.
This is what I'm trying to do as a developer but with different tools.
I realized for the first time that developing for Android could be a real job
when I produced my first app, Scratch Card.
Then some days after, I check on my AdMob Console and I saw my first five dollars.
It was incredible. It was
like I'm going to be rich!
With the money I made, I could pay my studies
and this was a huge goal for me.
Then I created Smart Launcher, that was a new UI for Android devices.
That has a very clean
home screen to focus your attention over the
main feature of your phone. And the other apps
are automatically organized in categories
The only platform that could fit for me would be Android because
Android is the only platform in which you can really do whatever you want.
I can work from another city, I can work on a cruise ship
but I decided to stay here in Manfredonia because here
I have my friends
I have my family, I have my girlfriend. I can work from here I
just need a laptop and internet
connection.
When I was going to publish my brother Daniele said
it's going to be your biggest failure. It's funny because if you saw the
number now
I think no one would say that. Now I have
more than
15 million downloads for the free version
and 200 thousand for the pro version.
My app is downloaded all around the world. It's really popular
It's really popular in India, in America, and also in Japan.
I think Smart Launcher is actually the product of Manfredoniamost exported in the world
Growing was something that was not expected.
Now I work with other people, and this is very exciting because now I can think to other products.
I think the future will be very exciting.
Success for me is doing what you want with your life.
For me it's living in my city with my parents
with my girlfriend, and being happy.
And I can do that, by being a developer.